[Music]
this episode is brought to you by we
work I love we work I haven't had an
office in many many many many many years
since 2000 or so when I had my last real
job I suppose and quotation marks but
when I moved from San Francisco to
Austin not long ago I decided you know
what I'm tired of working at home I'm
tired of working in coffee shops so one
of the very first things I did was to
get a space at we work I could not be
happier with this change in my life we
work is a global network of work spaces
where companies and people grow together
the idea is really simple you focus on
your business and we work takes care of
all the rest including front desk
service utilities refreshments and more
I also often have things shipped from
Amazon and elsewhere to my office that
we work here in Austin I've been
completely blown away by the
members-only events special offers and
perhaps the best cold brew coffee on tap
that I've ever had it's been amazing
it's been a real real change in my life
and improved my quality of life and
there are also dog friendly we work
locations all over the place how fun is
that we work caters to everyone from
entrepreneurs and freelancers to
startups and even large enterprises
including GE Salesforce Microsoft
MasterCard Samsung Spotify Pinterest and
redbull among many others in fact more
than 10% of Fortune 500 companies
currently use we work and it's a rapidly
growing group in other words it's not
just solar printers and the ground-level
startups that use we work but everything
from that to the big companies who are
seeing very huge benefits as well we
work believes that creating spaces where
people can connect and create meaning
together right and after all if you are
someone who is built
is modeled on the principles of the
4-hour workweek where elsewhere it can
be a lonely road sometimes even though
you're digitally connected it can feel
very very isolating so in these spaces
you can connect with real humans and all
the while use space more efficiently and
cost-effectively which makes you and
your business better equipped to face
the challenges of today and tomorrow we
work now has more than 200 locations so
you can find great spots all over the
world so head over to we co forward
slash Tim that's we Co Co so we got Co
forward slash Tim to become a part of
the global we work community at the very
least I encourage you to check out
pictures of some of the locations around
the world there are some incredible
spots so check it out we Co forward
slash Tim this episode's brought to you
by peloton and I'd heard about peloton
over and over again but I ended up
getting a peloton bike in the whole
system after I saw my buddy Kevin Rose
I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic I asked him as a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to because he's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't worry about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute etc
new classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which
is also fun Kevin I'm coming after you
but we usually just use classes on
demand I really like Matt Wilbur's and
his eye on high intensity training
sessions that are shorter like 20
minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is
Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say met
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so this $100
off is a very legit so if you want to
get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one pallet on.com and
enter the code - Tim again that's Ont PE
l OU t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the
code Tim at checkout to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out one
peloton comm code Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is typically
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers of different types and tease
out their habits routines favorite books
and so on so that you can apply them to
your own life
this episode is gonna be a little bit
different so if you want the long form
interviews go back a few episodes or go
to tim dot blog for it's us jamie for
jimmy fox or Jocko will link Tim dot
blog forward slash Jocko or whatever
might tickle your fancy this episode is
going to be in response to many many
many many requests related to my first
book the 4-hour workweek which recently
celebrated its tenth anniversary and
thousands of you have asked me how I
would update the 4-hour workweek today
and you've also asked why I have not
already updated the 4-hour workweek
which I did do in fact two years after
2007 and 2009 but why have an I sense
and to answer those questions and many
more I sat down for an interview where I
actually asked one of my friends Adam to
interview me to discuss common questions
misperceptions as well as how I would
walk someone through the book today what
I might expand if I were to at the age
of 40 as opposed to 29 expand certain
chapters and so on so if that's of
interest then I think this episode will
have something for you and if not the
long-form interviews will return the
very next episode and as always thank
you so much for listening
I am NOT Tim Ferriss but I am asking
questions to Tim Ferriss this is very
meta
alright Tim more than 10 years ago
4-hour work week comes out it's
published ten years later it is still
the most quoted book on Amazon
why has the book had such longevity this
is a curious question the answer is in
brief I'm not sure but I would say that
if I had to speculate and come up with
something I would say I wrote the book
very personally two of my friends and
the backstory on that is when I was
writing the book there are many
plausible other explanations and that
the 4-hour workweek is a title gets a
lot of people to buy the book and due to
the volume of sales there's a high
potential for highlighting since it is a
nonfiction how-to book right whereas
people are less inclined to highlight a
fiction book even if it is a thousand
times more popular than the 4-hour
workweek there are many plausible
explanations but if I had to take a stab
at how the content or the writing style
might contribute I would say that when I
started writing the book and it's
largely written in Argentina went back
to Buenos Aires where I lived for nine
months in 2004-2005 to write and the
first attempt failed completely I had
four or five chapters that were very
academic I was trying very hard to sound
smart and not say I never do that now
but it was really awful to read just
three syllable words where one silver
words would suffice and it was awful
which I think I actually developed in
college I think that in the process of
writing papers there I developed that
habit so I threw out those four chapters
four or five chapters and then I went
the opposite direction and tried to make
it
slapstick funny and really fast and
loose and it was equally bad just for
different reasons and in part both of us
failed because I was writing for a broad
audience I was trying to write for as
many people as possible and I couldn't
do it certainly couldn't do it well
maybe other people can so I sat down and
actually opened up a window to compose
an email and started as a first draft at
least writing a chapter to two of my
friends one who was trapped in a company
of his own making and felt like he
couldn't leave he couldn't kill his baby
it wouldn't run without him etcetera
which was the exact situation I had been
in and then another friend who is
working at a bank and was becoming a
victim of his own success he had no time
and was deciding to increase his burn
rate by things he didn't need to justify
how much time he spent working felt
similarly trapped and these were guys
around my age at the time 29 or so of 29
30 and I knew them really well because I
was effectively them I mean we had so
much shared experience so much shared
DNA so many shared goals aspirations
problems and so I wrote a very very
personal book ultimately with two
friends in mind and I think that the
feedback I very often get I don't think
I know feedback I very often get what
the book is I felt like you were writing
it just to me and I had a very very
narrow focus to begin with
meaning I'm writing for effectively
people who have very similar life
circumstances or goals aspirations fears
trappings and it was by definition if
you look at who's writing the book going
to be males in a fairly narrow age range
who are tech savvy very interested in a
handful of things but it's important to
realize that the the target isn't the
market and this is not something I made
up I don't know who originally to
attribute it to but my original target
just so I could write effectively from
my own
was that group but as soon as it came
out then it immediately bled over into
women who fit the same psychographics
and so on and then it started to bleed
out by age and now if I go I've been to
commencement speeches where the the
parents or grandparents will come over
and ask me about the for our work
because they read it and then I have
high school students who are reading it
so the original market was very very
very narrow that does not mean in some
cases certainly in the case of this book
that it can't expand later that's my
best guess that's my best guess is that
it's very personally written and it's
also in the category of advice how to
nonfiction which is prone to receiving
more highlights right to begin with so I
know you've been asked many times and
have thought about it as well about
updating the book because a lot has
changed in in more than 10 years but I
also know as does everyone else that you
have held back on that urge why is it
that you have decided at least so far to
not make any changes to to the book and
and updated yeah this is a good question
there this is something that I have had
a tremendous amount of internal debate
that and internal conflict about on one
hand I really want to provide the latest
and greatest and cutting edge to my
audience on the other hand in the format
of a book that is a losing battle
it is a fool's errand because as soon as
I update the tech and the tools it will
be outdated six months later it would
need to be completely rewritten in most
cases so if we look at the 4-hour
workweek I would say there are a few
levels to the framework and strategies
and advice in the book you have
principles to the first principles of
ordering principles that are the most
important if you understand those
principles you can usually come up with
say strategies which are broad
approaches to solving certain problems
maybe even framework
so we could call also the principles of
core beliefs or assumptions let's just
say then you have it or if then
statements right then you have the
strategies which are well given those
assumptions and first principles here
the broad strategies which do not
include tools or specific tactics then
you go up a level and you have tools and
tactics for instance using Google
Adwords to test which was very effective
and one of the primary options at the
time the 4-hour workweek was published
that would now be set at the very least
supplemented with say Facebook
advertising right and other types of
contextual advertising and testing and
so on and so forth there are many many
more platform options and testing
options than existed when the book was
first published in 2007 meaning the book
was written in 2005 2006 right it was
updated in 2009 so it's moderately
updated but the the tools and tactics
are always going to change and for that
reason I encourage people and the reason
I haven't updated those in the written
format in the book thus far is that if
you understand and focus on the
principles and strategies you can figure
out the tools and tactics right and in
fact you're going to have to do that if
you're going to choose to be an
entrepreneur so I'm going to make
something from nothing
let's just say very broadly speaking
someone who moves assets and resources
from an area of low economic yield to an
area of high economic yield which was
the one of the original definitions from
JB's say I believe his name was you are
going to have to become very good at
improvising and problem solving so if
you're not willing to figure out the
tools and tactics on your own I would
say you were ill-equipped or unwilling
to be what it is required to achieve any
modicum of success as an entrepreneur
right that's not just me absolving
myself with the responsibility of
updating right the principles and the
strategies are very important 80/20
analysis let's just say some assumptions
which could be falsified but that time
is the most valuable non-renewable
resource compared to say income right
all of these then inform the later
decisions
so a book is not the best format for
tracking technology nonetheless it would
be nice to update but it would be better
done via some type of community online
or online repository I tried that with a
forum and it turned into as you're well
aware in gigantic pain in the ass
headache so I euthanized that the other
piece of it is part two so if part one
is tools and tactics change too quickly
and I would have to put a lot of effort
into updating that would immediately be
obsolesce the second piece of it is
looking back say at the 4-hour workweek
there are parts of it that make me
cringe a little bit not that I regret
having written it the way I wrote it
but the 29 year old Tim Ferriss felt
like he had a lot to prove and he did
have a lot to prove I mean there are
hundreds of thousands of books published
every year and I had at that time no
media training I was utterly unprepared
for everything that transpired because
the initial print well the book was
first of all turned down by 27 I think
it's 27 publishers just a few violently
in some cases and then the initial print
run was between ten and twelve thousand
copies you couldn't even get it in many
places in the US alone the book was not
expected to do much at all and therefore
I was completely unprepared for
everything that came afterward in
writing the book also in writing for my
two friends I was very much myself at
the time and myself at the time I had a
bit of chest puffing very hyper
aggressive and looking back if I were to
edit the book now it would have a very
different voice it would have a very
different tone have a very different
feel but the 4-hour workweek now has
been translated into more than 40
languages it is almost always in the top
100 top 200 on Amazon like you said for
2017 it was the most highlighted book
across all of Amazon which was
even to me a big surprise and there's a
certain for lack of a better word
there's certain magic or alchemy in that
book that made it click and still makes
it collect ten years later that I don't
want to [ __ ] with I'm really afraid that
if I go in there and start tinkering
that I'm gonna step on the butterfly
that then you know causes like a
hurricane on the other side of the world
within the book that that somehow
effects what that book is done and if
it's not broken I don't want to try to
fix it so that's another reason why if
we look at not just the tools and
resources and so on if I were to go into
the book I worried that I would tinker
in a way that would damage it and if
people want to read the later Tim they
can it's very easy you just read the
later books right okay each of those
books is a snapshot of me at a very
particular point in my life and although
I wouldn't view them as autobiographical
they absolutely capture a lot of my
goals priorities neuroses and so on of a
given point in my life so those are a
few of the reasons why I have chosen not
to update the book if there was a
section or two which you've been asked a
thousand or two times to update yeah is
there anything that comes to mind that
now feels a little outdated and some
that when you think of today what you
are doing he would be like you know what
here's how I would refresh that section
there are a few sections I say broadly
speaking since the 4-hour workweek
broken into definition elimination
automation liberation the automation
section which talks about business
process outsourcing delegation the tools
that can be used for that certainly the
testing components of what we might call
now developing launching iterating on a
minimally
a Minimum Viable Product MVP those could
all be updated and I left out another
reason why updating is challenging and I
would take it one step further we're
talking about tools and tactics right
right we come down a level let's
consider the principles and strategies
let's take art as an example drawing all
right so you might have certain
principles and organizing principles
which are beliefs about materials and 2d
and so on for charcoal or some type of
drawing then you have strategies or just
composition and so on then you have the
tools given pens pencils and so on given
my audience right now if I recommend a
given pen right it is almost certainly
immediately going to be sold out that
problem which has been nicknamed the hug
of death by some of my fans applies even
more sort of services so if I recommend
a given service it currently has a few
thousand users or even tens of thousands
and then they get hit by a million or
two million it can absolutely destroy
the service particularly if it's not
automated and there's some type of
client interaction or customer service
if there is a manual component I can
completely destroy it so I am I am
loathe to in some cases recommend any
particular I get asked all the time all
right which outsourcing service should I
use I would like to get a virtual
assistant in the Philippines or India
who should I use well I've made those
recommendations in the past and within a
week they go from five out of five star
in customer service to one out of five
star right why because they suddenly
have to 10x their client capacity
overnight and very few service
businesses are equipped to handle that
almost none but if I had a gun to the
head and had to update particularly with
tools that can handle and scale maybe
they're based on AWS or otherwise right
Amazon Web Services are not as prone to
crashing
being destroyed then it would be the the
muse development testing components for
those people who don't know the term use
referring to a cash flow optimized
business that can scale effectively
without scaling and headcount or hours
necessarily and the other elements of
delegation and automation those those
those I think from a tool and tactic
standpoint are the most outdated and
therefore when I'm asked most frequently
for right so if people were to listen to
the podcast and read the book or read
the book and then listen to the podcast
as one would hope after 10 years there's
been as you've been talked about a shift
in in mindset and personality if you
were to rewrite it would there be a
section that you would add to that
obviously so much about mindset and
mental approach stoicism sign that has
come into your life would there be an
element that you would add that maybe
twenty nine-year-old Tim 20 year old Tim
never even realize the importance that
it played in terms of either growing a
business or having a mindset that allow
you to not only sustain say success but
happiness with that success I would
expand a section that I think gets
overlooked a lot there is a section or a
chapter called filling the void and it's
a really really really important chapter
that most people don't pay much
attention to and it answers the question
what should I do
once I have created a self-sustaining
semi or fully automated business that
funds all of my cash flow requirements
and I have location independence and
flexibility with time hence the chapter
title which is filling the void how to
reallocate your time and direct your
focus once you've gained a few rungs on
Maslow's hierarchy of needs right so
you're paying your rent you're covering
all your
all of your material needs then what and
this relates to a common misconception
of the 4-hour workweek which is oh the
objective is to just sit on a beach
sipping a piña colada rubbing cocoa
butter on your stomach for the rest of
your life
wait wait wait that wasn't the point
right or somehow being idle right the
the objective is to whatever just live
Spring Break 24/7 for the rest of your
life right and the the people who Lodge
that complaint a haven't read the book
but they they they very specifically
have missed this filling the void
chapter which talks about contribution
getting outside of a mimimi focus so
that you're hopefully putting a positive
dent in the world in a way that
certainly extends outside of yourself
and even your immediate family but also
hopefully has some type of persistence
over time so that you leave a este to
use the word because it's so loaded and
has some baggage but a legacy of some
type and so that really you're taking
the tools you've developed in a business
capacity and applying them to impact in
some fashion whether that's focused on
education scientific research where I'm
spending a lot of time actually focused
on both of those and have been for a
very long time i I think I would expand
that and make it clearer that that is
mandatory reading it's not a nice to
have when you have an extra few hours
five years from now you should read this
it's like no I expect that many people
skipped it because maybe they don't
expect to succeed right right they're
like hey I'll cross that bridge when I
get to it I don't have to even think
about it now and the fact of the matter
is you know thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people have
created these businesses and then they
[ __ ] up that part right and they get
even in some cases they get and this is
really common there location-independent
a lot of their friends have nine-to-five
jobs and what's
turn it off as a party in a celebration
oh my god I can't believe I figured it
out ends up being very very lonely and
they feel really isolated and they don't
know how to address that and the way you
address that is by digging your wells
before you're dry and thinking about
that filling the void and starting to
incorporate those pieces into your life
before you end up in maybe a challenging
emotional psychological position where
you're on your heels a bit you end up
being reactive or so set in your ways
even if you are even if you are
technically financially independent
since you haven't filled the void with
anything non-business related you are
just going to continue to work for works
sake this is really common this is the
default right for people who succeed in
any capacity to the extent that they no
longer need additional income or cash
flow or or liquid net worth it's it's
really common it's a very rare that you
find someone who's been in sixth gear
for a very long time who then retires
and is really good at chilling the [ __ ]
out not common learning to relax and
enjoy other aspects of life and engage
with people around you friends and
community or build community those are
skills you have to practice and develop
just like you need to develop and
practice the skill of split testing for
headlines or anything else it's not a
default ability that you have as soon as
you hit stop and so called retire or do
something like that
so I would spend a bit more time on that
I think that is the chapter that I'm I
was qualified to write at the time but
I'm much more qualified to write now
because I've had so much more practice
I'm just had put on a lot more mileage
and done a lot more experimentation and
have had the ability to observe dozens
and hundreds at this point of mega
successful people who have grappled with
some of these these issues that can be
really existential for someone if the
business has been your identity for a
long time and all of a sudden
you want to replace that if you don't
have a compelling replacement you will
just continue working because you don't
want to sacrifice that identity and how
how can someone possibly prepare for
that because I think what and you can
correct me if I'm wrong has probably
been amazing for you to see is the
number of businesses and success stories
that have born out of four hour work
week
you obviously expected when you wrote it
you would be able to help people but
over ten years the number of huge
businesses that have been started out of
thin air it's not even like you were
accelerating people quit their job
started this and it built out of nowhere
how do you take someone who's just like
and maybe maybe this could work and then
they do it and then next thing they know
they do it because they they want to
believe but they probably don't believe
in the first place but as you said if
you don't have that preparation you
might wake up one day and find yourself
in a position that you're you're not
prepared for so when yeah when someone
comes into this with the mindset I want
to give this a try so when people want
to lose weight everyone wants to lose
weight every wants to make more money
but very few people actually believe and
then they they follow the steps and they
get there and they're like oh what now
yeah how do you build a mindset that is
prepared for a reality that a part of
you probably doesn't even think is real
I would say in the beginning aside from
making sure you're exercising and taking
care of the highest value asset you have
you're going to need to throw a lot
against the wall with the business to
figure out what works you can't do an
80/20 analysis if you don't have
anything to add to analyze right so
you're going to have to try many many
many many many things to figure out what
you're good at what you're enthusiastic
about and to succeed and endure
respectively you need both you have to
have endurance and you have to have
ability and that can be god-given talent
or it can be skill that you develop but
in all of those cases you need to throw
a lot against the wall so in the
beginning there isn't going to be much
diversification of identity you're going
to have to really throw a lot against
the wall that's the front loading period
then you can start to do 80/20 analysis
so on out
once the business has enough traction
that you have proven what the tech world
would call product market fit and you
believe you might have a tiger by the
tail that you can grow in a meaningful
way once you have that there are a few
steps you can take number one is to
build a business that you can sell even
if you never plan on selling it this is
a very helpful not just thought exercise
but blueprint to keep in mind and lens
through which you should look at your
business and there are there are other
books out there that I think can be
quite helpful the e-myth revisited is
one looks mostly at service businesses
but could be applied to product built to
sell by Jon Warlow is a book that I
found very interesting to ponder and
when you start to look at your business
as something as another product that you
are going to ultimately sell you remove
single points of failure key man or key
woman risk you begin to really emphasize
process instead of just results which
you can get I mean if you're a type a
super driven person with some ability
and some numeracy so you can analyze
things well you can white-knuckle your
way to a fair amount of money but you
might be rewarding a really
unsustainable bad process because you're
getting good results and not only does
that not scale it's unsustainable you
will burn out or most people well
certainly or you'll be miserable and you
most certainly can't sell it unless you
want to be attached to it forever and I
would view that as lens slash step
number one is once you have some
traction and you believe that you can
pour gasoline on something that is
already working okay now let's take a
step back look at your org chart you
don't need a lot of headcount it could
still be a one-person business but how
can I automate certain things how can i
empower say freelancer
or fulfillment centers companies I work
with to make autonomous decisions and
otherwise create recipes and policies
that replace me as a bottleneck that
needs to make one-off decisions over and
over and over again that's really
important the second would be
simultaneously or shortly thereafter
diversifying your identity you asked
about happiness a bit earlier let's just
call it sense of well-being sense of
inner peace just feeling unconflicted
and unanxious perhaps what I found very
effective for that is diversifying your
identity what does that mean if the only
thing you do and having lived in Silicon
Valley for 17 years you know recently
moved to Austin but having lived in
Silicon Valley for so long you see
people who in some cases by necessity
unfortunately in a sometimes zero-sum
game of venture backed startups they're
only they're only identity is their
startup and if the startup has a good
day they have a good day and they feel
good about themselves if their startup
has a bad day they have a bad they have
a bad day and they feel badly about
themselves and there are factors outside
of your control when you run a business
clearly there are many factors within
your control but there are many many
factors outside of your control
macroeconomic climate stock market the
amount of disposable income that your
customers may have if you're heavily
weighted with say a handful of
distributors or clients and they
represent a large percentage of your
sales or income also a palpable risk
factor right and who knows like I first
I had an experience when I was running
one of my first businesses and the one
of my primary customers had a key man
risk ie a president who made a lot of
decisions yet he had a heart attack need
an emergency surgery and the second
command who was effectively the default
succession plan said hey we need to like
we need to stop a bunch of what we're
doing just to get back on our feet just
talk
understandable but it put my business
into a very reactive precarious position
all right so thinking through all these
but where I'm going with that is if you
are building a muse or businesses based
on the principles and strategies and so
on in the 4-hour workweek in some
capacity you I would encourage you to
diversify your identity which means
having say a consistent physical
practice than his goal based so when I
was writing for our body I had a dead
lifting protocol among other things
based on what Sprint coach Barry rawson
and awful pavel sat suelen which what
they had taught me related to developing
maximal and relative strength in the
deadlift and if I had a really tough
week with my book so authors do this to
it they go into this cave which is book
deadline and if they make progress on a
book in a week they have a good week
they feel good if they do not make
progress they hit a roadblock or are
simply having difficulty writing it can
it can throw them existentially into a
really dark place but all right had a
terrible day writing but put 10 pounds
on my dad left good day all right so you
have now multiple silos in which
independent silos within which you can
win and so you could have let's just say
startup or book then you have something
exercise based could be rock climbing
could be religion Brazilian jiu-jitsu
acro yoga it doesn't matter something
consistent ideally with other people all
right
not in your garage gym which I had at
the time but I chose to go to a rock
climbing gym where they also had weight
training facilities to be around other
people this is undervalued and then the
next piece could be anything could be
voice lessons could be a musical
instrument could be some type of artwork
it doesn't matter but these are three
independent silos or more I usually have
two or three so that if one of these
fails its self contained right sort of
like
any type of cruise ship or a large
Seabourn vessel at this point you will
have compartments so that if something
terrible happens it gets punctured by an
iceberg something like that the whole
ship doesn't go down
it is a self-contained controllable set
of damage right and I think that you can
view your identity very similarly and
you want to set that up before you need
it do not wait until one of do not wait
until your single silo fails to then try
to build the other two you have to
preemptively put it in place right so
those are a few of the things that that
I think about and have implemented quite
a bit for myself and that I've seen
successfully implemented by other people
I would call you overall insatiable when
it comes to the things that you want to
do the goals that you want to achieve
and the speed and level of achievement
that you want to achieve them in mmm-hmm
I imagine it was the same way when you
were writing this book but I also know
that you are much more reflective what
would Tim Farriss right now tell the Tim
Ferriss who was writing 4-hour workweek
knowing right now the success the book
has had how many people it has genuinely
helped and the difference it's made over
all to so many people's lives I think
this is gonna be a very dissatisfying
answer that always works uh I don't
think I tell him anything until the book
was done because and this is this is a
dissatisfying answer than a lot of my
interviewees on the podcast give me and
I'm always like come on but they're like
hey much like me with my hesitancy to go
back and edit the 4-hour workweek it's
like I don't want to step on that one
butterfly that then changes everything
right higher trajectory and if you think
about it in a given day I remember I was
I was contemplating this at one point we
think of life changing as big events X Y
& Z was life changing X Y & Z changed my
life some big event but
almost every decision every act you take
at every given moment in a day is by
definition life-changing you just used
to breathe in a certain way or hold your
breath or drink coffee instead of water
these are all life-changing events if
you were to look at two parallel movies
of your life
choosing a take and an uber versus
walking I mean these can all change your
life so I don't underestimate the impact
of seemingly small changes I wouldn't
say anything to him until he has
finished the book even then I might say
nothing but if I were to tell him
anything at maybe a few critical
junctures I'd say everything's gonna be
okay you can probably get what you need
done
but dial back the anxiety and worry at
least 20%
I don't think Tim of 29 would have
listened yeah I would agree but
nonetheless maybe I would say something
like that what I would probably say to
Tim at multiple points is something that
came up in tribal mentors my last book
repeatedly which was there have been
multiple points where I have felt like a
failure or have experienced what from
every vantage point objectively looks
like a business failure or a publishing
failure or a huge mistake
gigantic [ __ ] and something that came
up a lot in interviews for the last book
was sometimes you need life to save you
from what you want so you can get what
you need this is another reason why I
now ask so many people what is your
favorite failure meaning a failure that
in retrospect set you up for a much
larger success later and I've really
suffered from overly fixating on and
worrying about what seemed like or
seemed like failures
that's caused me a lot of pain and both
in the present moment and looking back
at it and wondering about the persistent
effects of that so-called failure so I I
think I would say hey I know this seems
like TAS trophy at the moment but this
is actually going to open a door that
you can't even imagine right now to
greater opportunities and that might
sound like some [ __ ] shallow
motivational speaker nonsense like in
fact like trust me I can't tell you what
it is just like this is going to serve
you and that's true I mean if you look
back at for instance the very difficult
experience which was publishing the
4-hour chef um and I won't go into great
detail about this but it was an
incredibly difficult book to write very
proud of it but almost killed me I mean
physically it was one of the most
difficult books to write put together
very complex a lot of moving pieces it
was because it was published by Amazon
and was the first major acquisition by
what was then announced to be Amazon
publishing it was boycotted by everybody
Barnes and Noble Indies big-box
retailers people wouldn't carry it and
it was it was an extremely extremely
painful let's just say two to three
years for me and I was burned out I was
completely burned out so I was I was
really just depressed and demoralized
and felt like hiding from the world
during and after that experience I was
so burned out that I decided to take a
break from writing and I decided to do
something lighter because during the
promotion of the 4-hour chef even though
the book didn't perform the way I had
wanted it to I had this experience with
the new format called podcast and I was
interviewed by Marc Maron and Joe Rogan
and the Nerdist gang including Chris
Hardwick and I had so much fun during
this podcast and I could be myself and
we could get into the weeds because it
wasn't two to three minutes on
television I wondered to myself what if
I tried that and just like those guys
edit very minimally and use it as an
opportunity to get better at asking
questions
to get rid of some of my verbal tics and
use it as an excuse to talk to more
interesting people and record it and be
more social because I'm prone to
isolating myself why not why don't I
give that a shot and try it for six
episodes so if I hadn't had what I
considered a complete catastrophe at the
time this podcast wouldn't exist which
has turned into something much arguably
much bigger than all of my books
combined at least based on feedback from
listeners and certainly based on monthly
reach that's one of many many examples
so I think I would say look just trust
me because I'm your future you so I know
more than you do
actually kid this seems like a mess but
you need life to save you from what you
want sometimes to give you what you
really need and trust me this apparent
failure is going to give you like a
hundred ex on the flip side just be
[ __ ] patient and don't do anything
stupid and self-destructive because
you're really depressed and sad right
now that's what I would say and how
important is that that the failure can
really happen at any point yeah and when
you think about 4-hour chef you had two
number one bestsellers at that point and
for a work week I think was on the
bestseller list for forever it's a good
way to put it yeah like for almost five
years straight yes so knowing that a lot
of people associate failure at the
beginning when they start but the
failure can happen at any point and that
resilience is important how much does
that almost even a lesson that needs to
be applied to for a work week if someone
is picking it up or going back or
thinking about giving some of the
recommendations to try I think
resiliency as you said it's saying it
you've learned but is it something you
can prepare for as you tried to start
something new which is scary for anyone
there are many ways to practice it in
many ways to train yourself I won't beat
a dead horse on stoicism since I've
certainly talked a lot about it but
stoic philosophy Seneca Markus realize
have both been very very helpful and for
those people who have no familiarity I'm
not going to get into it but you can you
can google Tao of Seneca I put together
gigantic compilation the
it's contains some of my favorite
writing it's available for free as an
e-book you can find it easily Tao ta o
of Seneca but you know everyone from
Bill Belichick right competitors supreme
in the in certainly in the football
arena to George Washington Thomas
Jefferson I mean you go through
prisoners of war from Vietnam War and
and other periods have all cited or in
some fashion actually Bill Belichick
hasn't personally cited but I know that
the Patriots Seahawks and so on at every
possible level have consumed stoicism as
a means of competitive advantage but in
terms of developing resilience and
tempering emotional reactivity so you
can make better decisions that's a
fantastic tool it's really a toolkit
that's one in general I would say on a
daily basis and this is especially true
for me in the last six months actually
with the help of Tony Robbins so I've
gotten to know over the last few years
and Tony is one of those people who it's
easy to be skeptical of Tony I've always
been a fan I mean my very first business
was a byproduct in part of listening to
personal power to which I bought used at
a used bookstore and listened to and my
crappy hand-me-down piece of [ __ ] green
minivan which my my co-workers
affectionately nicknamed the molester
mobile thanks guys
not because I'm a molester but because
it was a [ __ ] beat-up minivan that
looked like something out of Silence of
the Lambs and had the seats stolen out
of the back which didn't help matters
the long story anyway I would get stuck
in traffic on 101 in the Bay Area which
anyone who's done it knows sucks and
listened to Tony Robbins back and forth
so that's very largely responsible for
my first business in a case I've gotten
to know Tony over the last few years
I've attended two of his events have
spent a lot of time with him in person
had him on the podcast a couple times
and he's more impressive the better you
get to know him and what would he really
drove home for me in the last few months
is the importance of trying to identify
your
Maree question or primary questions that
you ask yourself as a means of dictating
behavior and it's very often something
subconscious so it could be and this is
very common for folks you know am i good
enough or why am I not good enough or
what the [ __ ] wrong with me like these
are very common default questions that
unsurprisingly then result in many types
of debilitating thought patterns
neuroses sabotaging behaviors in
relationships whatever it might be and
spending time and Tony's the right guy
to look to for direction on that I'm not
going to do it justice here but figuring
out your default questions and then
crafting new default questions so my
default question or one of my default
questions now that I try to revisit on a
daily basis because again you have to
practice this stuff it's not like you
just decide write it on a piece of paper
and then your life has changed forever
and your behaviors upgraded indefinitely
no you have to practice this stuff is
how can I even more so appreciate this
as a gift and there's there's there's
there's a bit more nuance to it but
let's let's take a simple version how
can I appreciate this as a gift and
specifically that is to be used when you
are frustrated when someone is
challenging you when you get an email or
a phone call you hate that throws you
into a tizzy when things happen that you
would normally look at as a problem or
perhaps at best a challenge like how can
you view this as a gift
oh you're stuck in traffic gonna miss
your flight okay this is a chance to
practice because guess what you're
missing your [ __ ] flight no matter
what so how can you view this as a gift
what is this an opportunity to do that
is another way to develop an ability to
reframe quickly that is incredibly
pragmatic and incredibly effective
for becoming less reactive and more able
to be responsible in the sense of
response able your choose
your response and that perhaps more than
anything else if you want some semblance
of well-being or a feeling of inner
peace it is that it is not by the way I
mean if you look at a lot of the noise
and craziness right now in the media
cycle there are many people who are
training themselves and encouraging
other people to try to make everyone in
the in the world change their behavior
to make everyone other than themselves
less offensive right this is the
opposite of making yourself resilient it
is much more much more practical and
possible to train yourself to be less
easily offended to train yourself to
reframe so that you can take people many
of which are never going to change the
behaviors and repurpose what they might
present you with as an opportunity or a
gift this doesn't mean you don't call
out terrible behavior it doesn't mean
that at some points you don't put on
brass knuckles metaphorically speaking
and like Dex someone in the face yeah
there are times when you fight but if
your default is always fighting not a
good approach you're not going to have
the stamina or the strength to actually
fight the larger necessary fights and
you're going to exhaust yourself and
you're going to alienate people I
remember a very good friend actually I
won't mention him by name but mutual
friend of ours said to me at one point
who works with very very high level
players in many different worlds he's a
bit of a consigliere and he said to be
over dinner once he said so I was I was
laying out all these various initiatives
and causes and so on I want to pursue in
the new year this was a few years ago
and he said I think you should as a
thought exercise just imagine that you
have six bullets you have a revolver six
bullets and that's all you get to spend
over the next year or two you have six
things you can take really seriously and
do very publicly that's it so pick those
very wisely which is not unlike Warren
Buffett's approach to saying here's your
here's your card
you have ten hole punches those are the
investments you get to make for the rest
of your life just as a means of pumping
the brakes and making better decisions I
think that's a useful useful way to
think of things so those are a few few
things that come to mind I will not make
you to a request of your audience or ask
you what will go on your billboard but I
will ask you that if someone were to go
back and reread the 4-hour workweek or
if they were to pick it up for the first
time as you mentioned tons of people are
still discovering this book which is I
think part of the beauty of it what
would you tell them to keep in mind as
they're reading through it to really
make it or allow it to have the greatest
impact on them I would say a few things
number one is that if the the brash
aggressive Tim Ferriss and it was a [ __ ]
out of you at points you're not alone
and try not to throw the baby out with
the bathwater meaning I am conveying in
that book principles strategies
approaches that I have collected from
other places and other experts so if for
whatever reason the tone annoys you try
as an exercise to absorb the message
without getting obsessed with the
messenger number one and for what it's
worth that's not true for a very high
percentage of people but there's some
folks for whatever reason many valid I'm
sure fine find the tone particularly in
the first baby chapter two to be a
little off-putting
so just go into it maybe expecting that
and ride it out second I would say that
the the tools and practices like the
fear setting chapter and the fear
setting exercise 80/20 analysis these
are not one and done practices these are
practices like having blood work done
every quarter or once a year that you
repeat over time
and that become more and more valuable
over time the better you get at
implementing them and the better versed
and more nuance do you become in using
them
that's what I would say those are - and
then last perhaps which relates to
everything we've been talking about is
focus first and foremost on the the
different reframing of assumptions about
life and principles the core tenets of
the book the strategies and don't get
overly distracted by the tools and
tactics so if you're not interested in
building your own business
or building a business along the lines
of what is described in the book that's
fine just focus on the higher-level
concepts and this has been applied by
many many many people I mean if you look
at some of the most successful venture
capitalists or billionaires who
certainly do not have what they would
consider 4-hour workweek nonetheless a
lot of them have read this book and been
quoted in the New York Times and other
other profiles that that are out there
you have people working in say education
or defense contractors or even attorneys
who have read the book and operate at a
very high level who are applying the
principles in some fashion maybe just
10% and seeing very dramatic results but
not building a business so don't get
fixated on the the type of pen that is
being used or the type of crayon that's
being used look at the look at the
concepts of composition and then the
principles of drawing in artwork and
learn those because they are
transferable to many different areas
awesome thank you Tim all right yeah my
pleasure
knife hanging out
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour work week calm all
the spell out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin Rose another forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic hey I asked him as a
dude you looked great
what the hell have you been up to he's
always doing a weird diet for another
but it only lasts like a week or two so
he always regresses to the mean after
like 75 beers and he said I've been
doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't worry about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute
etcetera new classes are added every day
and this includes options led by elite
New York City instructors in your own
living room you can even livestream
studio classes taught by the world's
best instructors or find your own
favorite class on demand and in fact
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and
you can compete with your friends which
is also fun Kevin I'm coming after you
but we usually just use classes on
demand I really like Matt wilfers and
his Iying high-intensity training
sessions that are shorter like 20
minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is
Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it
in a large closet believe it or not and
it fits with no problem so peloton is
offering all of you guys listeners of
the Tim Ferriss show a special offer and
it is actually special visit one peloton
that's fo n e PE l OT o n 1 peloton calm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say Mac accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so this hundred dollars off is
a very legit hundred dollars off so if
you want to get in your workouts if you
want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high-intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone
check out pillows on one pallet on comm
and enter the code Tim again that's Oh N
EPE l o t om calm and enter the code
tama check out to receive $100 off any
accessories including the shoes that you
will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim this episode
is brought to you by we work I love we
work I haven't had an office in many
many many many many years since 2000 or
so when I had my last real job expose
and quotation marks but when I moved
from San Francisco to Austin not long
ago I decided you know what I'm tired of
working at home I'm tired of working to
coffee shops so one of the very first
things I did was to get a space that we
work I could not be happier with this
change in my life we work is a global
network of work spaces where companies
and people grow together the idea is
really simple you focus on your business
and we work takes care of all of the
rest including front desk service
utilities refreshments and
I also often have that ship from Amazon
and elsewhere to my office at we work
here in Austin I've been completely
blown away by the Members Only events
special offers and perhaps the best cold
brew coffee on tap that I've ever had
it's been amazing it's been a real real
change in my life and improved my
quality of life and there are also dog
friendly we work locations all over the
place how fun is that we work caters to
everyone from entrepreneurs and
freelancers to startups and even large
enterprises including GE Salesforce
Microsoft MasterCard Samsung Spotify
Pinterest and redbull among many others
in fact more than 10% of Fortune 500
companies currently use we work and it's
a rapidly growing group in other words
it's not just solar printers and the
ground-level startups that use we work
but everything from that to the big
companies who are seeing very huge
benefits as well we work believes that
creating spaces where people can connect
and create meaning together right after
all if you are someone who is built of
business models on the principles on the
floor work week with elsewhere it can be
a lonely road sometimes even though
you're digitally connected it can feel
very very isolating so in these spaces
you can connect with real humans and all
the while use space more efficiently and
cost-effectively which makes you and
your business better equipped to face
the challenges of today tomorrow we work
now has more than 200 locations so you
can find great spots all over the world
so head over to we co fold / Tim let's
weed co-ceo we dock go forward / Tim -
become a part of the global New York
community at the very least I encourage
you to check out pictures of some of the
locations around
there are some incredible spots so check
it out
we Co forward slash Tim
[Applause]